Here is the French flag with three colors blue, white, and red. So, here it
looks like we have to make three decisions. Are we in the first third, the
middle third, or the last one? In java you would start out with the first
condition, and I'll leave it to you to fill in the details in the exercise.
Then, for the next part, you'll use an else if clause, so you simply write else
if followed by another condition. And finally, you use an else for the
remaining possibility. So, here you need to supply two conditions, is the point
in the left, is it in the middle or otherwise, of course, it has to be in the
rightmost part. This construction with if, else if. You can have other answers
if you'd like. And then, finally is a else. This is what you do anytime you get
multiple decisions. And I get worked down from the top to the bottom as you
would expect. The first condition gets checked if it's fulfilled the statement
is executed in here, and everything else is skipped. On the other hand, if the
first condition wasn't true, one would move to check the second condition and
if that one was true, it would be executed. If it wasn't, then the third one
would be executed. In other words, exactly one of these three blocks is
executed, depending on which condition is true or whether none of them is true.
Well, now it's your turn to try that with the French flag. Again, you'll be
given a point x y that could fall anywhere within the flag. And you need to
make a decision whether to return blue, white, or red. And when you do that be
sure to use an if, else if, else construction.